[Music]
today we're reviewing the 40 80 12
gigabyte which actually changed the name
now it's the 4070 TI problem solved it's
a hundred dollars cheaper so you have to
keep an extra one of those except this
is a partner model that's priced at 850
so it's actually 50 more expensive than
that so you split the difference
it's Prof money before you leave a very
angry comment So today we're going to be
reviewing the 4070 TI and uh we're doing
things a little differently in this
review let's get started before that
this video is brought to you by us and
our brand new limited edition
disappointment build t-shirt on
store.gamersaccess.net this shirt
features an Unholy amalgamation of all
three brands gpus glitching and
artifacting on the front as they were
intended it includes accurate depictions
of their designs and vibrant colors
printed with sustainable water-based
inks on the back we have the most
disappointing dates of 2022 in their
launches which conveniently feature the
RTX 4080 12 gigabyte that we're
reviewing today except now it has a new
name so we'll be able to put it on two
years worth of shirts we use high
quality shirts and long lasting fabric
dyeing techniques to make these and the
best way to support our in-depth testing
and independent reviews is to grab one
on
store.gamersaccess.net we're only doing
three rounds of these and they sell fast
so grab one soon so first of all as we
get into this review we actually went
back and added this small section in
because Nvidia made repeated verbal
claims about a 3.0 X increase in
performance and it was clearly just in
one hand-picked game and their
benchmarks they showed at their CES
presentation a day before the launch of
this review video and uh we took issue
with it Nvidia didn't really tell the
truth at least not the whole truth in
that image they tweaked it and they
didn't even have the usual sort of legal
disclaimer here's the footnote on their
slides just as three times better tied
T.I and yeah it says RT overdrive and if
you're familiar with the scene you can
deduce that it's an unfair comparison of
DLS S3 versus dlss2 it is not a directly
linear comparison they are benchmarking
basically dlss in a flawed way rather
than comparing the 3090 TI to the 470 ti
so saying a three times performance
increase over the 309 DTI is as we said
in the news video yesterday completely
unachievable it is a terrible
expectation to set with your customers
and it will crush the launch as a result
Nvidia is making this way worse for
themselves by this marketing this BS in
the day before the reviews launch but
fortunately it's not that hard to insert
a section so here it is and now let's go
back to the normal review so we're doing
things differently in this review to
just get straight into the dumpster fire
that is the 4070 TI here's a chart in
total Warhammer 3 at 4K the RTX 470 TI
ran at 67 FPS average placing it just
between the 3080 and the 3090. let's
just stop there and emphasize that we
have no idea what the hell Nvidia was
thinking when it originally named this
thing a 4080.
cutting off four gigabytes in the title
doesn't really change the name of the
product as we've talked about the GT
1030 in the past and this one it's
pretty bad they are completely
absolutely insane this is crazy that it
was ever going to be even considered to
be called a 48 because this is an 850
dollar RTX 470 TI it's 50 bucks more
than MSRP which okay fine it's whatever
a better cooler but originally it was
going to be over 900 and Asus then
pulled the stickers off as Nvidia told
them and replaced them with stickers or
paint that's in 4070 TI instead and
Nvidia dropped the price and probably
gave some kind of rebate to the board
Partners all at the past event video
which that's not asus's fault but the
crazy part is that selling it at 900
originally when it is already
barely equivalent to an RTX 3080 that
sold for 700 that's crazy Nvidia forced
itself into a completely unwinnable
position with this if they went through
with this and called it a 4080 that
would imply zero generational uplift
between two cards with the same
generational naming structure the same
class 80 versus 80 zero change for an
extra 200 or so MSRP with that original
approach instead of course they dropped
it to a 4070 TI they dropped the price
as we reported they would do months ago
to 800 so great only 100 more than a
3080 to get the same performance and
call it a 4070 TI
the names are kind of arbitrary but as
we showed recently in our the RTX 4080
Problem video they're not really that
arbitrary so this is why Nvidia is in an
unwinnable position they've backed
themselves into a corner and the only
way this was really avoidable is if they
killed this SKU entirely and never
talked about it or maybe if they killed
it after the announcement but then it
was too late the partners had already
made their cards so they were going to
get screwed so to not throw away the
product their two options were sell a
4070 TI that performs the same or within
a couple percent depending on the game
and you'll see more later sometimes more
but performance the same as a 3080 in
this game simultaneously calling it 70
class silicon and admitting
intrinsically that the 70 class silicon
has doubled in price over the last three
generations or has increased charitably
about 60 percent in one generation so
that's a bad answer they are then left
with option two the only other option
here other than killing in the product
and option two would be to say that it's
a 4080 that has zero Improvement versus
the last generation 80 card both look
terrible so good job Nvidia you chose
you chose an option
so the message they're sending then is
that uh at best there's no architectural
leap generationally in two years or at
worst you oh that's right YouTube
has new rules now so um I don't know if
this is going to be monetized anymore
but uh please buy one of our shirts if
you'd like to support our ability to say
things like that on
store.gamersaccess.net at least that's
monetized anyway at this point GP is
like it's like Whose Line Is It Anyway
where the prices are made up and the
cards don't matter let's move on to the
overview so of course the specs tell us
the Fuller story this is not and it
never was an 80 class piece of silicon
the cut down from the 40 80 16 gigabyte
is huge it falls from 9728 Cuda cores to
76.80 the memory cut down was only part
of it and it's the only part that was
reflected in the name hence Nvidia
having to change the name if it didn't
want to be nailed really for lying the
consumers so it loses so much of the
core while also losing capacity and
memory bandwidth and that's what really
killed this product and yes that is the
verdict within I don't know like 10
minutes of the video or less it's DOA
Nvidia is trying to get too much out of
the high end and it's going to pay for
its greed this cycle we've seen it
happen before we saw it happen with RTX
20 series and now history is repeating
itself the sad part is at the launch of
the 30 series someone from Nvidia told
us unofficially that Jensen Juan the CEO
paid attention to and listened to the
price criticism in the 20 series and
that was part of the driver for bringing
the price down on the 30 series
I guess he forgot he's a busy guy he
can't keep track of things for more than
a year let's get back to testing in
total Warhammer at 1440p the RTX 4070 TI
at 137 FPS average is 14 ahead of the
RTX 3080. that's at least better than
the 4K result in terms of positioning
but it's still not great the RTX 4080
that the actual one not this one holds a
lead of 28 at a price hike of 50 percent
and it's a good thing that Nvidia has
invested in AI art because we can't tell
if the corner that it's painting for
itself is AI generated or just human
stupidity it's indecipherable really
accurate this thing at this point it's
incredible the options they have on the
table with just two benchmarks into this
review where their own RTX 4080 16
gigabyte which is basically universally
snubbed other than uh amd's assist there
it now looks even worse it's it's sort
sort of like this is an inverse upsell
at this point
except the thing that they're inverting
to is also insultingly positioned but
that's kind of what this is so it's such
a bad launch we haven't even mentioned
amd's results yet maybe that's the
strategy
just be so shockingly insultingly
positioned that people forget about your
competitor back to the Chart speaking of
the competitor the rx7900xdx ran at 180
FPS average leading the 4070 TI by 31
percent for 25 percent more money or if
we compare it to the 850 model we're
reviewing today 18 more money the 7900
XT didn't have much of a purpose when it
launched but it certainly inherited new
life with the 4070 TI's launch it
actually makes the 4070 TI look worse
and that's from the position of a card
that was not particularly compelling and
was itself a greedy upsell will skim
through 1080p the 4070 TI ran at 209 FPS
average which finally boosts it above
the 3080. that's a 20 lead so it's
gaining ground at lower resolutions now
unfortunately Nvidia has been marketing
for years that lower resolutions like
1080p are becoming functionally
worthless so we'll take their word for
it and say that that result is pointless
at this point actually it's kind of
feeling like like in Star Wars when
they're in the trash compactor thing and
all the walls are closing in it's like
that except I don't know if they're
gonna be able to escape it the 7900 XTX
in this chart leads the 4070 TI by 23
it's about the same as the 4080s lead in
that 1080p result Rainbow Six Siege is
up next in this game we frequently see
FPS higher than 300 for 4K and higher
than 600 for 1080p so sometimes we make
fun of how ludicrously high the frame
rates are now unfortunately it's
recently come to our attention that one
of you in the audience one of our
viewers has compiled a sequence of all
the times I've made fun of Rainbow Six
Siege and its frame rates uh and it's
just it's frankly completely
unacceptable and we won't stand for it
so no more jokes it will only be serious
from here forth at 4K the RTX 470 TI
manages to run at 212 FPS average which
is completely unplayable for even the
worst players in Rainbow Six as we all
know higher frames mean better games and
212 is below the visible threshold for
an adult human fortunately babies can
still see below 212 FPS average so if
you're considering a GPU for your infant
human you might want to consider the
4070 TI it's perfect for babies humans
lose the ability to see 212 FPS at
different agents but the median based on
our scientific research is approximately
16 and a half months plus or minus 472
months margin of error it's sort of
similar to nvidia's margin of error when
it announces the name specs and price of
a new video card back to the Chart the
4070 TI manages to out through the 3080
by a massive 10 FPS or 5 that's a
staggering lead it's almost even
noticeable not to mention the better
balance you get when the weight of an
extra 100 is removed from your wallet
you won't need to visit a chiropractor
anymore thanks 4070 TI thanks Steve this
result has it just behind the 7900 XT or
achieving 7 79 of the performance of the
RTX 4080 16 gigabyte at 1440p the 4070
TI runs at 414 FPS average finally
putting it into visible range by the
average human from what we've been told
anyway 414 FPS average means the 407 TI
just barely out does the 6950 XT which
itself was recently available for
cheaper and it allows the 7900 XTX a
lead of about 29 or about 14 or so over
the 700 XT the 40 80 16 gigabyte leads
by 21 once again establishing that
calling this a 4080 ever would have been
a completely insane decision months ago
when they unlaunched the card one of the
things I genuinely asked the audience in
our announcement of their announcement
of unlaunching the card was uh okay so
is it all fine now do we forgive them
and I have my answer it's no it's not
fine this is a terrible price at 1080p
the 4070 TI falls behind the 6950xt in
fact the 6950 XT now leads by five
percent the 6800 XT is nearly equal with
the 3080 not too distant behind Tomb
Raider at 4K is next the 4070 TI ran at
116 FPS average which equates it to the
6950 XT it's about 17 ahead of the RTX
3080. it roughly equals the RTX 3090 TI
you could look at this in two different
ways either the RTX 3090 TI was a high
priced last second cash grab of a
previous generation that from day one
lost its value because within five
months the price was cut by about 60
percent and then a few months after that
it was cut down to a thousand dollars or
moving on the 7900 XTX outperforms the
4070 TI by 23 with the XT non-second X
good luck with that editors leading by
seven percent at 1440p the 4090 and 4080
are obviously Bound by the CPU the 4070
TI isn't but it's approaching the limits
the 700 XTX and XT both managed to
outperform the 4070 TI here but once
again nvidia's performance on the 4070
TI is proportionally improving at a
lower resolution we'll skip 1080p on
this one since it's so limited in Final
Fantasy 14 at 4K the 850 RTX 4070 TI top
ran at 116 FPS average outpacing the RTX
3070 by 62 percent for only 70 percent
more money awesome that's great it's
really good progress that's 0.9 more
performance for every one percent more
money spent on the other hand you could
say it's 17 better than an RTX 3080 for
14 more Baseline MSRP or you could say
that the 4070 TI nearly named RTX 4080
12 gigabyte achieved 76 of the
performance of an RTX 4080 16 gigabyte
that wouldn't have ever created problems
and fortunately Nvidia wouldn't ever
consider naming a video card the same
thing as another video card that exists
on the market even though one of them is
something like half of the performance
of the one that has the same name but a
different memory solution
except it's a 1030 ddr4
so F1 2022 at 4K is next this list is
short because we only recently started
testing this version of the game
fortunately we don't need any more data
to know our conclusion on this product
the RTX 4070 TI ran at 121 FPS average
here allowing the 6950 XT a 10 lead
actually everything on this chart leads
except for the older AMD Hardware the
4080 holds a 25 boost with the XTX about
36 percent ahead at 1440p the 6950xc's
lead is reduced to nine percent and the
4080s advantage is reduced to 15 let's
move on to the next one strange Brigade
at 4K is next we like this one as a
Vulcan API test just to cover all the
bases for weird behaviors the only thing
weird in this chart is the 470 TI's
value
well it's becoming less weird with each
passing chart it gets beaten by an RX
6800 XT and it only outperforms the 3070
by 32 percent but it's 60 more money so
that's about a half a percent
performance increase for every one
percent more money this is horrible
value even if you adjust for inflation
still pretty bad the RTX 3080 out does
the 4070 TI as does the 6950 XT the RTX
4090 remains a bit of an island and
keeps its impressive performance
positioning that's enough rasterization
testing honestly we have a few more
games I scrubbed through them they're
all kind of the same results so Horizon
zero Dawn we have as well same type of
results we're seeing we're just going to
skip them they tell the same story The
4070 TI would have been a disgrace as a
4080 and Nvidia at least cut the price
but they knew clearly that they were in
an impossible position a conundrum if
you will uh with the 70 class naming and
the a high price being what it is so
this is still entirely a situation of
his own creation we don't feel a bad one
bit for
making it so painfully obvious how
poorly positioned this is and it was not
possible to recover this launch once
they had started the momentous
storm that they had created and followed
power testing and conducted at the pcie
rails and Slot we measured the RTX 4070
TI at 290 Watts for performance fee bios
or 286 for The Quiet V bios the 4070 TI
top is therefore about equal to the 6800
xtn power draw with the 4080 drawing 20
watts more the overclocked 4070 TI hit
307 Watts so even though it's fifty
dollars more in MSRP than the Baseline
thanks to asus's changes it's not really
giving us any additional overclocking
power outroom so pretty disappointing if
it were MSRP this boost would make more
sense the only promising aspect is that
the power consumption is much lower than
the 3090 TI but certainly the card
cannot hit that three times performance
number that Nvidia claimed transient
testing is up next in this testing we
use an oscilloscope to plot the
transient spikes or the excursions away
from the average power consumption this
is measured commonly in microseconds of
length they are very short in duration
most transients we measure are in the 40
to 200 microsecond range but we've seen
some as long as one millisecond another
RTX 4090 transients are important
because they tell us a picture that
averaging power can't tell just like one
percent lows does significant transient
spikes can cause a system to
unexpectedly shut down if the power
supply can't soak the sudden surge in
power requirement here's the charge in
this testing we want to see the Red Bar
be as close to the Blue Bar as possible
the nominal power consumption was
typically about 289 Watts but sometimes
it ran above or below that in F1 and
Port Royal we measured below the nominal
as in other tests the transient spikes
in Port Royal were pretty brutal
actually going up to 100 over Baseline
but the increase over the TDP is only
about 35 percent so if you're planning
for for the high average or 289 it's not
as big of a spike F1 transients have
about 61 from Baseline in the game and
then doom and Rainbow Six we're at 33 to
40 transient spikes so overall nvidia's
40 series architecture has drastically
improved in its power behavior from
previous generations this is somewhere
they're doing well it seemed like
they've resolved most of the massive two
and a half X transients that we saw in
the past that could knock some power
supplies offline this also partly comes
down to the Asus tough card design so in
that respect they're doing pretty well
here's a quick frequency task to
validate the performance the 4080 ran at
27.75 megahertz when we tested it with
the 4070 TI plotting a bit higher at 28
20 megahertz this is with the same test
conditions it's also somewhat normal for
lower end Hardware to clock higher
because it's getting rid of cores in
this case a lot of them so it has more
thermal Headroom to boost additionally
though the Asus tough card will perform
differently than an Fe and Nvidia didn't
make fe's for the 4070 tis is but it did
for the 4080 on this chart in thermal
testing to steady state we noticed the
4070 TI ran at about 61 degrees for core
average with a hot spot at 74 degrees
Celsius with the tough that is
fluctuation was higher than typically
observed here and the memory temperature
ran at 70 degrees Celsius all of these
numbers are acceptable and they're
within typical performance expectations
and the memory temperature is well
within the spec as for the fan it Rams
to about 1400 RPM and held for the
majority of testing fan hysteresis and
behavior were reasonably defined and as
far as asus's execution of V bios we
think the fan curve was well plotted Ray
tracing is up now Ray tracing is
complicated because we have to consider
both dlss on and off then of course FSR
for AMD and then just controlled with no
dlss at all starting with a control will
Benchmark control we're testing this one
without any dlss or FSR type tack at 4K
the RDX 4070ti ran at 39 FPS average
it's about equal to an RTX 3090 and it
allows the 39 DTI a lead of 21 you might
be asking yourself what happened to the
three times performance improvement over
the RTX 3090 TI oh that's right it
wasn't real back to the Chart the 7900
XTX leads the 4070 TI by 15 with the
7900 XT about equal at 1440p the RTX
4070 TI slightly passes the 3090 with
the 3090 TI's lead reduced to 13 percent
as the resolution decreases the gap
between them is closing maybe Nvidia got
its three times gain numbers by running
the tests at 480p with dlss 6.0 as for
the XTX it still leads with the XT about
tied Ray tracing for F1 2022 instead we
tested at 4K first and the RTX 4070 TI
ran at 44.5 FPS average that positions
it just behind the 3090 TI and we all
clearly have the same definition of a
three times uplift as Nvidia and they're
definitely definitely doing that here at
1440p and Ray trace the 4070 TI is again
behind the 3090 TI by a couple FPS cool
so basically What's Happening Here is
nvidia's entire 3.0 X increase claim was
predicated on the back of an unclaimed
and unfair dlss 2.0 versus dls's 3.0
comparison in cyberpunk and tested with
the same version of dlss on all Nvidia
devices that means no 3.0 and FSR on AMD
the 4070 TI pulls 45.5 FPS average at 4K
it's about the same as the 39 DTI
technically it's 1.3 percent better now
sometimes we like to give the benefit of
the doubt so here's what we think
happened when Nvidia claimed the 3x
increase we think that they saw this 1.3
percent advantage in the 4070 TI and
they accidentally moved the decimal
place one to the right and then they
accidentally changed the percent sign to
an X and then they accidentally deleted
the one at the front of it and it became
3x anyone could do it it's completely
understandable you only need to make
like four or five consecutive and very
obvious mistakes and not catch any of
them and that's how you get the answer
so on the chart the 4070 TI gives the
4080 a 12 FPS lead it's about 28 here so
definitely not fair to call the 47
dci4080 and the 7900 is just behind the
4070 TI this time it's between two hard
spots either they have to admit that
there is zero generational Improvement
basically or very very small amount
between a 40 80 12 gigabyte and a 3080
or they have to show to their customers
that they are now increasing the price
of the 70 class two times within three
generations which per nvidia's own words
is about the upgrade cycle or if you're
being charitable sixty percent increase
in one generation so that's where we are
those are are there only two options it
is simply untenable to choose either the
third option which wouldn't have been
feasible because they were too deep in
it would have been to cancel the product
entirely but it was too late for that so
this is one giant mistake of a product
launch for NVIDIA where they stumbled
into trying to go for the former option
and saying there's no generational gain
between 40 80s unless you enable DLS S3
at least as compared to the 3080 and
that also would have forced them to
admit that the 40 80 16 gigabyte is
really nowhere close to the 40 80 12
gigabyte if you're going by name alone
this was completely unreasonable to ever
call that that would be 10 out to line
to the customers which I mean again
it wouldn't be the first time that they
sort of oopsie we dropped a huge amount
of performance changed to something like
the memory and then now it sucks but it
has the same name or close enough to it
so the average customer who doesn't pay
that close attention to the letter g in
front of your DDR memory type gets
screwed the 4070 TI here they crushed to
themselves by setting the expectations
far too high with that 3.0 number yes it
looks like a nice number to say but it's
just so uncommon and it requires such an
unfair test condition it doesn't make
any sense if we're going to play those
kinds of games
yeah you might as well just go in and
tweak the graphic settings until you
find the one that hamstrings your
competitor the most and boosts you the
highest which
they'd kind of gotten away from those
types of games and videos whole Spiel
has been we Market on quality we don't
play stupid games well here's stupid
games and they got their stupid prize
the 4070 TI is simply demonstrably bad
value it is an insult that they ever
thought it could be a 4080 and renaming
it and dropping the price 100 bucks was
simply not enough so that's the review
um they where's my
I had to walk out of shot to get my
prize for NVIDIA here's a GN award
Crystal uh Nvidia has earned it by yours
on the store but it's it's right here
we'll leave it here so when you're ready
to pick up your stupid prize there it is
thanks for watching go to
store.gamersaccess.net grab one of those
or our disappointment build t-shirts
which have the three gpus outlined on
the front and they are limited we're
only doing three runs of these so grab
one on the store today to support our
work and testing thanks for watching
we'll see you all next time